I've been looking for you, let's go quickly, Mr. Nishimura.
Wait,
my swimsuit isn't weird. What's
wrong with that? It's okay, Mr.
Nishimura. Let's go quickly.
[Music] I
might have failed.
Maybe the Grim Reaper looked like he was trying his best.  I should have
liked Minami Chichi.
Hey, look! The
Shinigami is wearing an unnecessarily cute swimsuit. Kitagawa-kun was
here. Hello,
even though he is the
Shinigami, it's not
illegal to wear a cute swimsuit. Look, I
saw that Kitagawa-kun is also incredibly cute.  I can't believe
it,
Takada-kun. You're
always trying to be nice, too.
Look, I'm being sarcastic. Nishimura and others don't
look good in swimsuits like that. Kitagawa-
kun prefers school-designated swimsuits.
Kitagawa likes girls in school swimsuits. They look like
perverts.
Not because they're different, but who
knows what your
swimsuits are? Kitagawa-kun, I'm fascinated by girls in swimsuits. Don't make me
any more of a pervert.
Well then, there's
no point in getting involved with that guy.
[Music] Hey, he didn't want to hit me, so he
left. Ahino-kun came too.
Hey, you
'll be fascinated by this girl in a swimsuit. Maybe you'll be fascinated by
me.  It looks
like she's trying her
best to float around. It's embarrassing. That's right, Mr.
Nishimura.
That swimsuit is so cute. It
suits you so well.